what's the first step to start a
business so I got a great question for
my YouTube viewers love you guys from
the polybag collector who wrote it in
the say if you want to start a business
what's the first step you should take so
this is a great question the most
important first step Bar None is an easy
question for those of you who are low
subscribers of the channel you'll you'll
you already know what I'm gonna say you
have to find your passion you have to
build a business around something that
you are passionate about you have to be
a little bit crazy to be an entrepreneur
because it's going to be really really
really hard and nobody really talks
about how hard it is to be an
entrepreneur you just hear all the the
good things and the big wins and the
huge successes but it's really hard it's
gonna be the hardest thing you've ever
done in your life it's starting a
business and making it successful it's
that hard the same people the logical
people the normal people they're gonna
quit because it gets too hard so you
have to have a little bit of crazy in
you to be successful as an entrepreneur
and it's it's that deep love and passion
for what you're doing the things that
you would do even if you weren't getting
any money even if you're not getting
paged and I need to keep doing this
because it's important one of my
favorite examples is George Lucas who
started Star Wars and Lucas Films and
Indiana Jones and his first six years in
business was were failure complete
failure six years and his friends and
his family said George do the safe thing
get a job like you what are you doing
you're not this is not working okay one
year two years six years it's not
working man stop you're crazy and what
kept him going it wasn't that he wanted
to try to make a lot of money is that he
loved films and he said you know what I
don't care if I ever make money on this
I have to find a way to keep going
because I love it so much that's what
kept him going that's what you need to
find to keep you going
Lucas now is worth over four billion
dollars he's a multi-billionaire but he
only got there it was never about the
money for him he got there
he loved what he's doing so the number
one most important rule how do you get
started
find your passion do something that you
love and keep doing it every day find
something that you can't live without
doing you have to create this thing in
the world because it's a part of you and
you have to share it and help other
people achieve whatever their goals are
that's your first rule believe for those
of you watching the video thumbs up
below
let me know what you think leave a
comment below ask me a question I'll
make a video response and click on my
face if you want subscribe to the
channel and see more videos like this
thank you so much I'll see you soon